Film Courage: Do you remember the first time you
picked up the camera? Bruce Logan, Writer/Director/Cinematographer: I do I haven't I
have a photograph of it and it's me and
to raise who was a friend of my parents
and there's a picture of me with this
it's not a box brownie but it's like
it's one level up from that and you can
see me kind of struggling with the
controls and I guess I must have been
free something like that you know and
and then later on I picked up my
father's he had this Kodak camera that
had the bellows that opens up and the
bellows stick out and I did a lot of my
early work with that camera and why not
keep it as a hobby what how did you
there's so many kids pick up gadgets of
all sorts what why continue on
I suppose I it was kind of in the family
because my my father worked for the BBC [The British Broadcasting Corporation]
he was a drama producer and he he was
one of the pioneers of three camera
drama and he produced about an
hour of live television every week and
even though I could see the stress on
his face you know it was it was
definitely an area that I was going into
so my earliest memories of my father was
he would come home and he would work at
home and he had a map of the plant view
of the studio and then because the
cameras were all they all had cables on
them he would have a piece of string on
this like plastic representation of the
camera and and where it plugged into the
the wall and his his job was to block
the show without a camera ever running
over another cable because they were on
wheels and they couldn't they couldn't
run over the cable so that's like a very
early memory of
me and his workflow but no if I only
really ever wanted to be two things and
one one was a film director and the
other one was a rock and roll star so I
can animate and John Bonham's [Led Zeppelin drummer] job was already
exactly what's he crowded professions
you grew up in the United Kingdom I did
I I was born in central London on the
Tottenham Court Road and I believed we
spent our early years and Notting Hill
Gate and then we moved out to what was
then the country but it was really
suburbia to a place called bushy Heath
which is near Watford which is where
Elton John owned his football teams so
that gives you a reference and it was
also situated halfway between Elstree
Studios and Pinewood Studios so for me
it was a really good place to live
because I can commute to either one of
those studios and then at what point did
you leave the UK well I got a my dream
job which was to work for my favourite
director ever standard Kubrick on a
movie called 2001 a Space Odyssey and
that was when I was 19 years old and so
I worked for like two and a half years
on that movie which is actually the
longest gainful employment that I've
ever had in my life you know in in one
stretch and at the end of that movie I
was asked by Doug Trumbull who had
originally hired me onto that movie to
come and work for his new special
effects company in California so I came
right after that movie in 1968 and
really I've been here ever since
it's my country
at that time what was Kubrick's um he
wouldn't have been a legend of course at
that time as he was in his 20s or early
thirties no he was I'm not sure what age
he was but he was definitely a legend he
you know my dad had taken me to see PATHS OF GLORY which was his first big picture
I think with Kirk Douglas and they had
these wonderful tracking shots through
the World War 1 trenches and it was also
a courtroom drama so I think that was a
you know before that he had done two others but they
were they were smaller movies so I think
positive glory was his first in a really
big movie and then you know he made
movies like Lolita and Dr. Strangelove
or how I learned to stop worrying about
the bomb and loved it
I think that's the byline of the movie
and no he was he from me and because my
dad had taken me to see all these movies
and then some of them I went to on my
own he was a pretty big deal he was mine
he was my favorite director so to get
hired by him that movie was the stars
must have aligned very carefully for me
to get that opportunity and you know I
had some really good breaks in my life
you know but I've always been ready for
them I'd always laid the groundwork so
when I got when I got the call to work
on that movie I had I had a very strong
training in animation so I was hired as
an animation artist and then that when
they found out I could shoot animation I
became especially interesting to them
because there's a process in animation
where the animators animate and then the
animator they write a dope sheet which
is an instruction sheet
to tell the the cameramen how to shoot
it so it's it's a it's like frame by
frame it tells the camera and what to do
so I was able to do the artwork and then
put it on to the camera and I've skipped
that dope sheet phase of the process so
I became very useful to them in that way
and that's how I got promoted very
quickly you know do you remember what it
was like the first day you reported for
the job
yeah I was excited to be there but I
certainly wasn't nervous about it you
know it was I think it's the arrogance
of youth that you don't really know what
you stepped into and I just felt I felt
very at home I felt very supported by
everybody that was around me and you
know I had this background in animation
I had taught myself you know I was a
huge Disney fan as a kid and when I was
about 12 I wrote a book on how to
animate cartoons which was a focal press
book and I taught myself how to animate
and to do cells and then my dad bought
me a nine point five millimeter camera
which was able to take single frames so
now I was able to get my animated
drawings and turn them into animated
films so I had done that and then after
school I got hired by an animation
company to do to be a trainee rostrum
cameraman a Russian Russian cameraman
the name of an animation or a
photography process so I had done that
and so I had this whole background that
I'd been working on for years so it
seemed like I I got this really lucky
opportunity and I jump right into it but
I had this underlying base of
knowledge and practical skill in that
before I before I got there
do you remember your first meeting with
Stanley Kubrick I do originally when I
came to work at MGM we were in the front
offices because the the production
hadn't really taken over the studio as
it would in in you know within within
six months we were on every stage and
every department but at the moment that
we were in this little tiny front office
building you know they had probably
about eight or ten offices in that and
so I'd started off working in in this
room with Doug Trumbull who had hired me
and another guy from the Film Board of
Canada called Wally gentlemen
and there was Stanley just kind of like
walking walking through the offices and
he seemed very relaxed he was smiling
and laughing and joking and a very
affable guy you know and and very very
personable so he was you know pleased to
meet you and it was I remember well he
came in with Arthur Clark who had
written or co-written 2001 with him he
had written a short story that Stanley
had based it on and the end they were
just wandering through the office there
was no like formality to it you know it
was just it was very nice and and
Stanley's office
remained open throughout the throughout
the production so you could go into his
office he had a he had a newer on his
wall saying no half-baked idea you know
you don't want to come in with anything
that you haven't thought about and
present to him that's not not a
formalized plan you know so very
interesting guy you know so really an
open-door policy not just what some HR
paperwork says exactly yes yeah and and
you know he he was you know he had some
strange toy
to him he he he liked to have nothing in
his pockets so I think I think he come
you know in America you have to carry
your ID and your wallet and your car
keys and you know so he had had nothing
on him
so he would bum cigarettes off other
people so he didn't have to have a pack
of cigarettes on him
and he drove in this plastic rolls-royce
that was at the studio and he had a
driver but that was really the only the
only kind of you that you could call
formal pretense of something that's
around it and and I have to say I was a
very irresponsible kid when I was on it
and I would frequently be late to work
so it would be like 9:30 and I'm coming
into the parking lot and the only other
guy that's walking into the studio was
it was Stanley you know and he he never
seemed to be angry with me for not being
there was just like a nice polite wave
and I'd go in so so it was weird because
there wasn't really a pressure to work
the pressure of the work was on you so
as I so it seems like I would come in
and we would look around and would talk
about what we've done today before and
then it was tea time and then we'd have
tea and then it seems like nothing
really got done before lunch and then
and then round about three o'clock I'd
start really shooting in earnest and by
the end of the day I don't more footage
shot than anybody else that was doing
the same kind of work you know so it was
the arrogance of you but I guess with
some talent did you have long hair I did
I think that's another reason I was
hired you know he looks like the Beatles
you know
we should hire him were you well
received being so yawns that or were
there other people that were 1920 know
that what people as young as me I was
really the youngest around and I was
very well received in our little group
but I think a lot of people in the
English film industry it's a much more
kind of clothes and nepotistic loop you
know then than it is here and that was
one of the great things about coming to
America was everybody was very open
about everything and invested in your
success but there was always kind of
like her there was always a feeling like
no he's he's around he's maybe a little
too big for his britches in there over
there so some you know the people in our
department were very very enthusiastic
and and helpful but others were a little
like what what's he doing here you know
that's not sure about that
you